this man has had enough Heimlich lesson
Vorta has declared war on motorists he's
fed up with drivers simply taking away
his bicycle paths and using them as
parking spaces
he's had enough and is taking things
into his own hands his weapon his
smartphone he wants to put illegal
parker's in the virtual pillory and he's
developed an app for that take a photo
note the location and upload it to the
Internet a copy with the location and
license plate goes to the police
uncompromising and unforgiving avoiding
off dessert want to draw attention to
what's happening here constantly we want
officials to pay attention cyclists we
simply want to get safely from point A
to point B become city officials in the
Berlin district of panco are aware that
there's a bike accident on average every
two hours in the city punko official
tossed in kuna was enthusiastic about
the idea of the app there was even
cooperation with the self-styled bike
sheriff but at the last minute the local
administration decided the new weapon
was too dangerous s captain his eagles
escape there was a lot of skepticism
about this app as a method of
communication there was a lot of worried
that it could encourage denunciations to
i bethought at VN quinta but heinle
schluss inviter won't relent now he's
putting the app on the market himself
he's already invested many hours of his
free time and ten thousand euros the
bike sheriff shows us his virtual map oh
my god is even one test here in the math
you see test entries there will be a lot
more at some point for instance here you
see typically blocked bike paths or
double parking where parents don't dare
ride past with their kids oh you're
causing father them and when the next
cyclist goes flying or a child is
injured then you have a look at these
maps and say dear officials dear police
why didn't you do anything wrong sounds
like I don't even put its high about
opportunities need to come out
but that's meant to change he hopes his
new app will report thousands of traffic
violators to police across the country
officials in Berlin are concerned the
crendon would English better fuel and
Zack we can only tell the people who
complain that we'll look into it but we
will not be able to follow up on
everything when police dispatch plans
are made they might be sent to those
places where traffic violations have
been reported ok so these Titans of all
buttons it
the motorists lobby is also viewing the
sheriff app with skepticism that
conflicts are in out of the conflict
between motorists and cyclists could
just escalate if we keep reporting each
other and posting it on Facebook or
other websites then the hatred and
resentment will just keep growing alpha
nanoha long Visenya but highly Sheila's
mata is convinced that he's fighting the
good fight he says cyclists simply
aren't respected and feels they deserve
respect he says his app will help them
get it
you